hi there this is the demo video of flexi
funnels which is the ultimate all-in-one
online business solution and in this
video i'm going to show you
how easy we have made it with the help
of flexi funnels for anybody to
go online or to start and run and manage
their entire online business just with
the help of one flexible software all
right so uh let me show you all the
things step by step
number one is let's suppose whenever you
know when whenever you log into flexi
funnels this is the dashboard that you
are going to see uh
in your case you know when you will log
in for the first time you won't see
these projects so
of course you know these are my
individual projects when you will create
for yours so you will be seeing yours
right so the first thing that you are
going to do is you are going to click on
create new project all right and over
here you are going to select that what
is the kind of
sales funnel or the you know what is the
kind of funnel that you want to you you
want to create right now let's say you
know you want to create an opt-in funnel
sales funnel
product launch funnel you want to launch
a course host a webinar or whatever it
is so let's say i want to launch a sales
funnel okay
and i give it a name sales funnel demo
all right
so the first thing that you are going to
do is you are going to click on create
new project after that your project is
getting created in the backend all right
now when it comes to launching a sales
funnel all the things that are part of a
sales funnel we have put them over here
of course you can add your custom pages
as well but at the same time we have
added all the things you know the the
things that are mostly used in a sales
funnel now the first thing that you're
going to do is you're going to be
creating your pages site of a sales
funnel so let's suppose let me uh
let's let's uh we want to create a
opt-in page okay so out of all the
templates that we have given over here
and they are more coming by the way so
you will select the category that you
want to use of the templates right and
let's suppose over here we have all the
opt-in templates let's suppose out of
all the templates maybe
you want to use
uh let's say this one okay let's say
let's let's select this one by the way
you can click on the preview and see the
uh preview of all the templates for
example you know i just want to see that
how is this template looking in actual
so i can see it right over here so now
this particular template is selected
okay i can click over here edit page
so we'll give it some time to load
because the
you have just selected a template so all
the things are coming from the back end
all right
all right so now you have all the things
with respect to your template right over
here
right so this is good to go even right
now but of course you will want to
change some of the things so you can
replace this with your logo
replace this with your image right and
all the things are easy drag and drop
right over here let's suppose i just
want to change the
size of all these things for example you
know i want to
increase the size of this particular
headline so i need to go to the text
settings and i increase to i i will
increase the headline size okay let's
suppose i want to change the color of
this maybe i want to make it let's say
green you know corresponding to that i
will make it black as of now or let's
say i want to change the color of this
thing you know i want to make it let's
say
yellowish kind of you know i can i can
do it right now uh maybe i want to
increase or decrease the size that you
have already seen right so that's
you want to change the font and
everything uh
then you want to add something in the
background for example right i'm not
gonna add it right now or maybe you want
to play with the margin let's suppose
you know you want to add the some size
over here or let's say let's let's talk
about this opt-in form
let's say you want to uh you know
add some borders and stuff like that so
maybe you want to add a
border with a white color and maybe i
want to increase the size of the border
right so that's something that can be
done or any kind of customization
basically anything and everything can be
made using flexi funnels as you can see
that you know this is a really good
looking design
and we have like you know so many
templates already plus at the same time
you want to create anything custom that
is of course you can do it you know just
like that you know you can you can go to
the page settings add any kind of
element add any kind of those for
example we have all these those let's
suppose you want to add something uh
maybe i mean just an example maybe you
want to add a demo video all right so i
want to add a headline
um
and i just want to rename it
let's say i want to call it a demo video
right
and uh let's
increase the size a bit
all right and you want to change the
font let's suppose
all right and next thing is you want to
add a
video over here so you can add a video
just like that and again right over here
you can play around with the settings
and stuff or the spacing you know you
want to add some space over here maybe
some margin over here or you want to add
a video now you know you want to add a
youtube video or a vimeo video or any
other video you can just put it right
over here
uh
so basically all the all the elements so
we have all these sections right we have
all these this is this is a menu section
by the way if you want to add a menu on
the
uh page and then we have all these those
to give it any kind of layout one column
two column three column four column six
you know all the kind of layouts that
can be possible for example something
like this
let's say i want to have a some you know
column like this in which some part
needs to be bigger some part needs to be
smaller or maybe a column like this you
know vice versa or you know something
even more smaller you know you can see
the comparison or i want to uh you know
change the
size of this thing let's suppose you
know i want to go here over here and
make it full width instead of this being
you know half width or something like
uh smaller width of course i can then
play around with the settings and stuff
right i want to make it let's see even
more
or
let's let's put it back that was looking
good of course then you can change the
settings and then you can change the
size and everything okay
and once these things are done then what
you need to do is of course let's delete
it not looking good so i just want to
delete it right now
and once all of these things are done
once you are you know happy with your
page once you have designed it you just
click on publish
and after publishing the page it will
get live on the url you can see the step
side you can see it right over here your
page is getting published please check
in two minutes
so all these things are happening right
over here
at the same time i will click on the
published url at the same time we have
all these settings over here for example
you want to change the favicon or you
want to add some codes on your page you
know in the head or the body or you want
to play with the seo settings of the
page the title description
and keywords author do you want to show
it in the search engine or not right and
do you want to add any pop-up to your
page or maybe you know do you want to
enable lazy loader uh in your page
settings i mean all these trainings just
in case you are not aware we will be
providing to you inside the platform
and once you are
done with your page your page is going
to be published just like this so this
page is live on the internet you don't
have to worry about you know downloading
this page uploading to your wordpress
site or to your hosting this page is
already loaded right on the internet
using our fast cdn service let me show
you the speed of this page right just in
case you missed it have a look at this
do you see within one second or maybe in
less than one second the entire page
loaded right over here
so this is how we have made flexi
funnels the entire page is always going
to load in less than one minute in less
than one second i mean to say right so
this is this is this is how quick we
have made the page hosting and
everything and uh
now once the pages are done
so let's suppose you know once once you
are done with the pages
uh let me also show you a quick uh
overview of the integrations that we
have inside flexi funnels so
basically uh
let's suppose if you are using any order
responder you want to pass on the data
to any order responder of your choice so
of course we have all the integration
with all the famous autoresponders right
over here and at the same time we have
the
price code so basically just in case if
your choice of autoresponder is not over
here you can bring the form code from
that particular responder and you can
put it inside the
page builder so that is something that
will pass your data to your responder
plus we also have the webhook to you to
be able to pass your data to the
autoresponder plus we have integration
with the payment gateway platforms all
the things are very easy you know step
by step instructions have been provided
we have integration with the webinar
platforms we have integration with the
domains so basically you can add your
own domain so for example if i go to
this page this page right now is added
on my account which is sb.lexicons.com
by the way in your account you will be
able to edit this thing so you will be
able to have you know your name or any
other custom sub domain that you want to
add and you will be able to use that
at the same time if you want to add a
domain you know any any particular
domain to your account that is also
something that you can do you just need
to go to the settings and over here you
just want to add a domain and it will be
done and the instructions are always
going to be very easy this is what my
team have done you know played around
with the settings over here
anyways so you can simply go over here
add a new domain just in case let's
suppose you want to add a domain
let's say abc.com all right
so you just simply add the details just
add the domain and then we'll provide
you with the instructions you just need
to go to your
domain from wherever you purchase the
domain edit the dns and you know add
this this thing over there this ipad is
over there this is something which is
very simple you just need to
uh you know understand if you just want
to understand how to do this we have
given the instructions in a knowledge
base side over here and still just in
case you need some help how to do it you
can simply reach out to our chat you
know live chat support right over here
click over here send a support ticket
and we will help you with the entire
procedure all right so your domain is
going to be added just like this
and
yeah and once you have added your domain
let's suppose you know you want to
connect your domain to a particular
project you want to connect your domain
to the particular set of pages you just
need to go to the general settings of
that particular project
and uh select the domain let's suppose
i'm selecting this particular domain so
now all the pages that are the part of
this particular project are going to get
loaded in this particular
domain all right so this is how simple
we have made it
so
yeah what next what next so let's talk
about selling a product all right let's
talk about selling a product that let's
suppose you want to sell a product
online uh let's open this page by the
way
so if you will see everything is fully
automatic the domain has changed by
default okay so you don't need to worry
about anything
right so
this was loading on this particular
domain for the first time right and
every time uh next time you will open
any page of this particular project it
will be loading very quickly all right
so now this thing is done let's talk
about uh
let's say creating a product that you
want to sell online okay so the first
thing that you will need is a sales page
of course go to the templates of the
sales page
and let's say you want to select any
particular template over here maybe for
this particular example let's simply
select this one
right just just one example at the same
time let me show you the preview of this
or maybe the preview of this
and just very randomly maybe this
okay so now we have selected this right
so this is this is the one that we
selected okay
i mean just just a random template that
we selected very quickly okay so by by
the way if you will look at the design
we have all the templates having very
good designs and all the pages are fully
you know mobile responsive by default so
you don't need to worry about the
responsive part of it okay these are
some other extra templates i mean
there's so many templates by the way
right so you don't need to worry about
the
uh you know uh responsiveness of the
template so the sales page is now
selected let's select a checkout page uh
because we want to sell the product and
let's suppose for the checkout uh maybe
i want to select let's say this
particular template okay
all right and let's say let's have a
final thank you page okay so for the
thank you page we are yet to upload some
of the templates of the thank you so
just for randomly as of now let me add a
upsell template in thank you as of now
okay let's select let's select this one
uh this particular template
okay so now when we are done let's go
back to the sales page
and let's edit a few things over there
let's make sure that the page is
published so that you know we are able
to use it
so you will have to publish the page to
ensure that the page is live okay
all right so if you will see the entire
thing entire back end has loaded over
here and i just need to click on publish
we don't want to do a lot of changes
over here i just want to click on
publish okay that's it
although we will have to come back to
this sales page in just a couple of
moments but i will show you okay
all right so this thing is getting
published it takes about a couple of
minutes for the page to be entirely
published since
it is going live on the internet it is
going live to all the cdn servers
which ensures that the page speed
becomes very fast so this entire process
takes about two minutes and then it will
be live on all the pages so the world
okay
i mean on this particular url of course
okay so this thing is loaded completely
over here let me go back to the pages
right if you will now you will see the
message so it takes a
few moments to
publish the entire page because it is
you know we have to ensure that it is
set up globally it has gone globally so
we take a few minutes to
show the final update but as you can see
the page was loaded like
even before that
now let's add a checkout template i mean
let's just uh publish the page the
checkout page
and once all our pages are done once our
sales page is done once our checkout
page is done once our
let me click on publish so this is good
to go right once our sales page is done
once our checkout page is done once our
you know this thing is done
uh what do you call it thank you page is
done so after that we are good to go by
the way uh this is the bump offer
that we are coming up with as of now it
is not live at the time of making this
video but uh by the time the launch
happens you will have this bump of a
settings as well you know so you will be
able to use bump office to be able to
increase your
average revenue right so this is
something that we are testing right now
so
yeah
just wanted to make you aware right
all right so the checkout the uh page is
also loaded let's have a look at it and
as you can see with any page you know
they are loading just in a flash you
know it hardly takes one second to load
the entire page even if we loaded the
entire sales page you know it was a
big page you will see it was loaded just
in a second right as you can see all
right so the checkout page is done now
finally we will go to the thank you page
and we will load the thank you page
so
again same process we'll click on edit
we'll click on publish
and then we'll go back all right
okay so clicking on publish
and let's have a look uh you know let's
see if it is published right now
uh yes it is already published right
like i said that it takes a few bit of
seconds to show the entire message but
yeah we do it pretty quickly which we
just want to ensure that you know uh we
are sending the right message and it is
loaded everywhere so we show it in a few
moments right
okay so this thing is now done we are
done with the pages we are done with the
sales page checkout page thank you page
so now what we are going to do is we are
going to
go to our the flexi panels dashboard and
now we are going to create a product
that we can sell all right so
let me click on the product tab
or maybe i will click it and open it on
a new tab
and i will go to click on back over here
because we need to do some work over
there now let me click on create a new
project uh so what do you want to sell
do you want to sell a digital product
right now or the membership product
membership product is basically a course
okay
let's suppose i want to create a digital
product right now and uh
let's give it a name so let's say sales
funnel
demo
this part is in the live mode payment
options i want to connect my razor pay
the price so i want to give it a price
so let's say you know let's say 10
rupees for this particular example
uh sales and checkout page so basically
we need to select the sales page and the
checkout page so we'll select the
project first and in this we are going
to select the page that we created as
the sales page same thing we need to
select the project first and then we
need to select the
uh checkout page that we created as a
checkout page in this particular project
now in the
uh
thank you uh after purchase settings
basically so what is your support url we
will we will put that plus what should
happen after the purchase
same name thank you page that's right
sales funnel demo and then we are going
to select the
thank you page
uh what about the digital asset so this
is basically uh you know let's suppose
you want to sell any ebook or a pdf or a
jpg file png file or any kind of small
file that you want to sell or you want
to deliver to your users so we have a
settings for that and you can put it in
the background
in the backend and when you select all
the digital assets whenever the digital
asset is sold or this product is sold
they will get access to it automatically
okay so this there's like so much inside
flexi funnels but all the things i
cannot cover in the small demo video so
of course we have you know detailed in
sections for using flexi panels side
over here you can go to the tutorials
tab inside flexi panels you can go to
the knowledge base so over here we have
everything right but in this particular
demo video i'm going to give you a
complete overview of all the you know
bigger level things higher level things
but in the trainings and everything we
have detailed trainings for each and
every single thing that will give you
clarity of each and every
uh you know features of flexi funnel
site so we have all the detailed
trainings right on this particular page
all right
so i'll just close it as of now so uh we
are done with this particular step right
i will click on save
and there's another thing which is set
rules so basically say tools means that
whenever a product is purchased where do
you want to send the data do you want to
send it to any autoresponder of your
choice or you want to pass it to some
webhook so all those things you can
select from here right
so i'll click on save so this prod is
now created i'll go to click on back now
i'll go to this particular project i
will go to the sales page all right and
i need to click on edit
okay okay so the only thing that we need
to do is we need to connect the
product the sales page with the product
okay and for that what we need to do is
we need to click on the button and over
here we need to click on go to the next
step in the product and over here we
just need to select the product so let's
suppose you know this is the product
that we want to sell right now so i just
need to click on publish
and now i need to wait for the
final message that this page is
published right over here okay
all right so this page is now published
all that i need to do is i need to go to
the published url
i have this page right over here and now
when i will click on this particular
product
okay so you will see that the checkout
page has loaded and in this particular
checkout page my product has loaded
along with the price that we gave to the
product okay so all that i need to do is
let's suppose i want to make the
purchase let's suppose with this email
id
and i want to
um yeah
click on complete order
okay so what i'm gonna do is i'm going
to
select
upi slash qr code so i'm going to
complete this payment with the help of
my phone so allow me just a couple of
seconds
so just getting the payment done just a
second
so
all right so now the payment is done
and if you can see we have moved to the
thank you page right so this was the
thank you page that we selected and we
have lightly moved to the thank you page
right
so
the product creation part is this right
but how do we verify that the payment is
done so for that you need to go back to
your products we created this particular
product right and you need to go to the
statistics
and over here you can see the complete
data you know this this was the email id
with which we made the purchase uh the
payment gateway that was used uh the ip
address of the buyer along with that the
price status and the date if in case you
know
you you had added more details on the
checkout page for example things like
name phone number address uh zip code or
any other details so all of that data
would also would have also come over
here right at the same time if you want
to export this data you can do that
right over here right so this is where
all the product creation is done
now let's suppose if you want to create
some uh good sales funnels
so basically some advanced sales funnels
with this peg tool let's suppose
creating the oto products downside
products and you know people going from
one oto one to oto two to down sale and
all those advanced logics so you need to
come to the funnels tab
and inside the funnels tab you need to
click on create a new funnel okay let's
suppose i click i select sales funnel
demo all right
and let me click on create a new funnel
and over here
this this funnel is now created i need
to click on edit to go inside and over
here i need to select my front end
product okay so let's suppose this is
going to be the front end the product
that we just created right and over here
by the way all the detail trainings all
the detailed instructions of how to use
these funnels and everything has been
covered inside the tutorials okay this
is just uh your
the overview that i'm giving you right
now but we have all the tutorials and
sections everything right inside flexi
funnels okay
so let's suppose if somebody purchases
this we want to make them go to let's
say final mastery i mean
another product so which part is going
to be
so we will select it right over here and
now if somebody purchases this
particular product we want to make them
go to let's say
this particular product right
so all of these logics we have made it
very very simple let's suppose if
somebody does not purchase purchases
this particular product where do we want
to move them so in that case let's
suppose we want to move them to this
particular product all right and
similarly we can keep on creating more
logics depending upon how many products
do you have inside your sales funnel
right so do you want to make move them
to another product or another product
basically all these things uh you know
you will be able to create a complete
sales funnel with the help of this
particular option right now
let's talk about creating a course okay
you will go to the projects
and this time when you click on create
new project this time you will click on
launch a course because this time you
want to launch a course site so let's
say a sales funnel
course okay i mean just just a random
name
now when the membership project is
created what you need to do is you need
to go to the membership area and inside
the membership area you want to give
your course a name let's suppose the
name of my course is let's say
mathematics mastery okay
i mean just a random thing and over here
you will click on save now your course
is created but the the modules that you
want to add inside the course or the
lessons that you want to add inside the
course let me show you how the flexible
members area looks from the inside so
that it gives you the idea and then i
can show you the you know how to create
it so this is one of my courses by the
name copywriting mastery
which is hosted on flexi funnels and
that's how the membership area looks
from the inside right so we have all
these modules so these are all the
modules and these are the lessons inside
the module site so this this this blue
part is the modules and these are the
lessons so this is the let's say intro
video after that if i want to move to
the
next lesson i just need to click over
here and your user is your customize
will go to the next video if you will
see that the entire membership area you
know the entire journey from one lesson
to another lesson is very very quick if
i want to go to the next module all
these things we have made it very very
quick you know if you have
checked out any other membership areas
any other course areas of any other
product you know i have personally found
so many course membership platforms to
be very slow but if you will see we have
made it very very quick right
uh that's one thing
now if if when we want to create a
course ourself what we need to do is we
need to come over here and we have
created the course we want to add a new
module let's suppose the name of my
first module is for example let's say
algebra
you can you can upload a picture of your
module right
and by default one lesson would be added
but if you want to add more lessons to
it you can simply click on add a video
listen and you know more lessons more
and more lessons will be added right
over here at the same time if you have a
vimeo playlist or the youtube playlist
that you simply want to import you can
click over here and all the videos in
that particular playlist are going to be
imported right over here and all of them
will become individual lessons so that
is how we are saving your time right
so all these lessons are right over here
if you want to add uh let's say more
modules you can simply click on over
here add a module and let's say this
time you want to call it calculus just
an example right
and that's how simply you will be able
to add more modules and more lessons
inside your course just like we have it
right over here and when it comes to
selling the particular
course all that you need to do is you
need to go back to the products i have
already shown you how to connect the uh
sales page to the
you know a particular product to a
particular sales page right all that you
need to do is you need to click on
create a new product and this time you
need to select membership
right and over here let's suppose i give
it a name mathematics mastery all right
and make it live all of these settings
you're already aware of all that you
need to do is just that the only
difference is this time in the after
purchase settings you are going to click
on select a membership project and you
are going to select a course for which
you want to give access whenever
somebody purchases this particular
product all right and all the other
settings you're already aware of how to
connect this product to the sales page
and the other things right so this is
how simply
you can host your entire course and sell
it and give access everything right
within flexi funnels got it now when
this thing is done i want to show you
one more thing which is like very very
powerful very very you know
extraordinary that we have made inside
flexi funnels and that is the reporting
dashboard that we have inside
plexifunnels right
so uh this is something that is yet to
go live inside the platform uh
you know at the time of making this
particular demo video but by the time
the launch is gonna happen this
reporting dashboard is going to be live
inside the platform so basically
uh this is a this is an area in which we
show all the advanced analytics all the
advanced reports that you need to scale
your business so basically when it comes
to scaling a business
the number one thing that you need is
the you know statistics the analytics
that how your page is converting how
your funnel is converting which page of
yours is converting more which page of
yours is not converting well right so
that you can optimize your conversions
of every single step and that is how you
are able to scale your online business
so all of that data will show you inside
right over here so this is this is just
the starting point we are still working
on it we are still going to make it live
so from everything when it comes to
sales page views unique visitors sales
gross revenue how much amount was paid
to the affiliates this is basically the
reporting dashboard how much amount was
paid to the affiliates so yeah in the
future we are also going to add the
option for the
uh users of flexi funnels to be able to
launch their own affiliate program using
flexi models so that is something that's
going to come in the future
and then we have the overview dashboard
so over here you will have all the
uh detailed stuff you know how much
sales how much revenue how much uh
net conversion rate and all those things
will be coming right over here plus you
are able to
sort your data with the help of name
email id order id transaction id uh
let's suppose you just want to say
see the sales of any particular product
you can see it right over here you want
to see the sales with respect to the
currency in which the product is sold or
with respect to the date filter you know
for the particular date range that is
something that you can see over here
and you want to export the data you can
do it right over here at the same time
you want to see the payments data of all
the completed payments or the payments
data of all the failed payments so that
you can just see all the failed payment
data
and you can you know simply reach out to
them and get them converted so that is
also something that we show you right
over here plus all the sales that i've
got that you have got through the
affiliates or non-affiliates all of them
will be available right over here and
then we have the sales tab in which you
will have all the data let's suppose
last six months and all the database
filters along with that in which
currency the product was sold which
particular affiliate got you that
particular sale which particular product
is getting sold and you can filter it
with the help of visitors sales
conversions
earning per visitor earning by sale and
the you know total amount so as you can
see
you can see that you know all the
affiliates and all the data i mean you
know what is the revenue per visitor
what is the revenue per sale and all of
that right and at the same time you can
change the currency so all of this you
know advanced data is getting prepared
right over here and we are we are yet to
add more and that is the reason we have
not yet made it live inside the live
accounts this is the backend account
that you of course don't have access to
right so uh but yeah we are going to
make it live soon into the live accounts
right so yeah i mean that is what you
know we have uh made with respect to
flexi funnels uh you know we have we
have tried to make a platform which is
all in one online business platform and
when it comes to anybody
thinking to do anything online or when
it comes to anybody trying to scale
online we have created a platform that
is going to give them that all-in-one
solution so that they don't don't have
to worry about going to 10 or 20
different platforms trying to manage
their single online business and you
know all of them they can all of it they
can do just with the help of flexi
funnels right within their one single
account so
that is how easy that is how simple we
have made flexibles and at the same time
all the things that i showed you inside
this particular demo video this is
i would say just the tip of the iceberg
because we have so much more when it
comes to inside flexi funnels but of
course in a simple demo video i cannot
show you a lot of things of course but
when it comes to
when you become a part of flexi funnels
you just need to go to the tutorials you
just need to go to the knowledge base
and go through all the trainings and
stuff there's so much more there's so
much advanced stuff that we have you
know this was just the all the basic
level things that everybody has to use
but when it comes to doing a lot more
advanced stuff we have so much more
inside flexi funnels that you are going
to learn when you become a part of it
and when you see all the tutorials and
you will see that how easily all these
minor little things are going to help
you in scaling your business
with the help of flexi funnels right so
uh
yeah that's it for this particular demo
video i'm super excited to you know for
you to become a part of flexi pulse
number one number two uh you know uh if
you have any questions any queries you
can always reach out to us using the
support chat that we have we have a live
chat support inside flexi panels so
whenever you are stuck we are more than
happy to help you right over here right
so yeah thank you for checking out this
demo video and i hope to see you i wish
to see you inside flexi funnels and our
entire team would be ready to help you
in every single stage wherever you are
stuck with respect to you know using
sexy panels and we'll be more than happy
to help you right so yeah thank you for
checking out the demo video i wish to
see you inside flexi funnels